you mentioned you liked the t-shirt I
also like this one have our de nieve or
not knowing have you worked with Roger
no unfortunately not so this is still a
bucket list item yeah most certainly is
most certainly is but you know these
this kind of cinematographer sometimes
you don't even notice them sometimes you
don't even you know they don't interfere
they they they know what they're doing
they stay outside they kind of they're
unusually very quiet I love them but
what's interesting is pardon me for
going off on a Rodger tangent but I
found it fascinating that he only shoots
with one camera no coverage and like
what he of course they shoot coverage
well he was saying when I spoke to him
and with Dineen he was saying they
usually just do one camera he shoots or
that's pardon me for saying that that's
usually the directors choice anyway but
you should coverage with one camera as
well otherwise you have nothing to cut
completely let me switch off of rod now
that's interesting I could talk all day
about your stick to the hair I just want
to start by saying I love this movie
thank you and it is a were you sort of
like you so you get the script or you
they're telling you about the movie and
they're like and you're not playing the
villain fine that's not what I'm reading
looking for anyway so that's fine by me
let's stay with let's stay with Roger
and and the difference of one camera
shooting to how we shot a leader awesome
there were I think 36 or 46 cameras
installed in the ceiling for motion
capture alone there were eight cameras
that were hand operated to get the lay
of the land and there were two big 3d
cameras sometimes only one which would
be the equivalent of of you know Rogers
one camera and you we could have shot a
leader on that one camera it just would
have taken a little longer and I kind of
concur with Roger to to you know make
that one look deliberate um
but all that other other stuff all the
other cameras were there to capture
performances not necessarily mine
because what I did one camera could have
done but what all the others did
meaning the motion capture that is that
is a more involved process the result of
which now is that you get Rosa even
though she doesn't completely look like
Rosa even though her body is not roses
body but a cyborg body yet it is rolling
Bliley in completely yeah every little
twitch every little mannerism every
little you know look out of the corner
you even can see what she thinks if you
know what she thinks as I do because I
work with her you can see that even
though you would you would do from a
from a from a still you would say that's
a computer-generated image it's not you
know III think the visual effects in
this our groundbreaking they're
unbelievable I have to ask you though
you're on set you're filming in this
environment there there has to be an
element of even you know with James and
with Robert telling you about the movie
there has
you're using your imagination to imagine
what this is finally going to be what
was it like seeing the film for the
first time in scene that finished the
effects because they're so insane yes
well they are there they're insane yeah
possibly they're insane but no they're
actually pretty sane right they're just
very very accomplished and you know one
does not mean the other but but it it it
the the employment of the very very
elaborate visual effects still serve to
tell the story meaning the story as I
know it and as we were trying to to work
on it remained the same the human
behavior remained the same the the
visual effects were just a vehicle to
tell the story and and really just they
are not the the over overriding element
in this story it's a story it's still
you know smarts and hearts and human
communication even though it happens
between cyborgs at times but it's still
you know real people acting and reacting
and communicating with each other so so
when I saw the finished product I
thought it was fantastic
and I was interested in the story yet
this story is is great one of the things
that I really love about this is that
I'm not a huge fan of 3d but I think the
3d in this is exceptional
alright what can you sort of talk about
that aspect that you do want to see this
in three days well um
depth of vision
is actually a dramatic device okay in an
image it looks cool but if you discover
that you can look all the way down and
still see something that is interesting
and possibly relevant to the story then
its employed as drama and that's how it
should be because otherwise you could
see it flap and get the same thing and
it's never flat anyway you know there
there is depth in 2d as well but here
the depth is tangible physical and you
know if you look down that street of
iron City and you see people of all
kinds and and origin and appearance all
mixed together and you look further into
the next plane and further into the next
plane and it still happens like that you
say well maybe that would be something
to aspire to to have a world where we're
all together all the way into the full
depth of field and the mix of everybody
and nobody considers it extraordinary or
you know unusual
you